fist bump diplomacy as defence chiefs
from nato countries including the us and
germany arrive at alliance headquarters
to strengthen their stance on russia and
pour over the latest intelligence
and this is what they've been looking at
a russian defense ministry video
claiming to show a partial pullback of
forces from near ukraine the kremlin
says combat equipment and troops were
leaving the crimean peninsula seized
from kiev in 2014 and returning to base
the nato secretary general was quick to
dismiss any talk of a de-escalation of
tensions we have heard the signs from
moscow about
readiness to continue diplomatic efforts
but so far we have not seen any
de-escalation on the ground
on the contrary it appears that russia
continues the military buildup strong
words too from european union chiefs in
strasbourg urging moscow to come to the
negotiating table
the choice today is between war and
tragic sacrifices that would go along
with it or the courage of a political
engagement a courage of a diplomatic
negotiation very clearly the european
union chooses diplomacy and chooses
negotiation we will demonstrate
discourage
[Music]
there was little sign of any russian
troop withdrawals in belarus on
wednesday this another show of military
muscle for the cameras joint exercises
would be russian troops only deepening
fears in neighboring ukraine that an
invasion is imminent
on the land and in the air nato says
russia has reached full combat readiness
but there is a shred of hope in recent
days russia has signaled that it would
be willing to join talks that door
remains open
do too much and nato runs the risk of
being drawn into a long protracted
standoff with russia do too little and
it runs the risk of a possible invasion
in ukraine something that could
destabilize the whole of europe
russia is creating a new normal said
stoltenberg by using force to contest
the principle of sovereignty in europe
the alliance he said must respond
possibly with a new nato battle group in
romania the hope of an easy end to this
standoff is fast fading neave parker al
jazeera brussels
well we have two correspondents covering
developments this hour in a moment we'll
go to our white house correspondent
kimberly hackett in washington but first
to natasha butler who's monitoring
reaction from ukraine's capital kiev
natasha as this nato defense ministers
was being held in brussels today ukraine
was holding a day of national unity a
so-called day of national unity and the
president has been speaking about it
tell us
more yes vladimir zelensky ukraine's
president saying that ukrainians are
strong that they are ready to defend
themselves that they are ready to fight
fight he says whether it's february the
16th 17th 18th april or september now
zalenski was talking from the port city
of mario paul in the southeast of the
country uh very close to the front line
where ukrainian forces have been
fighting russian-backed separatists now
for nearly eight years so it was a
highly symbolic choice of location and
this is the day that zelenski has called
a day of unity in ukraine he called for
this a couple of days ago the idea is to
try and rally some patriotism uh to try
and say
send a message to moscow that ukrainians
are united that they would fight if they
were attacked and he chose this date of
february 16 the significant date it's
not a date chosen by chance but it's the
day that uh some western intelligence
sources said that russia could begin an
invasion
and so what has ukraine been saying as
far as russia's claims that it's been uh
withdrawing some of its troops including
from crimea what's their assessment of
russian troop movements
well zolensky also touched on that
earlier in the day he said look shows
the proof show us the evidence uh he
says he has not seen any evidence at all
that russia is drawing down any of its
troops on ukraine's board and we know
that is the same sentiment that we have
heard from other western allies that
they simply haven't seen the evidence
the foreign minister here in ukraine has
said look this seems very much along the
lines of what we've seen before from
russia that they say one thing but they
actually
do another however the foreign minister
did say that if there was to be any form
of drawdown then that would be certainly
welcomed as a sign of de-escalation uh
from moscow it would be seen as a sign
that the diplomacy is perhaps working in
the meantime i should say as well the
ukrainian government has also commented
on these huge cyber attacks that took
place on tuesday night here cyber
attacks that the government said
targeted two major state banks the
websites of the defense force and the
army huge attacks they said on a scale
they'd not seen before even though they
didn't damage any infrastructure just
the web pages uh ukraine's president
again zelinski said uh when it comes to
those cyber attacks that the government
here believes that foreign forces are
behind those attacks he is not pointing
the finger at anyone in particular or
naming them but again western
intelligence has said in the past that
russia could use cyber warfare against
ukraine natasha thank you for the update
natasha butler is our correspondent in
kiev there let's now go to our white
house correspondent kimberly halkett in
washington d.c kimberly where do things
stand as far as the white house is
concerned
well fresh warnings of potential cyber
warfare in the united states as well
from the fbi the national security
agency warning particularly defense
contractors to be wary of potential
attacks particularly when it comes to
not only military plans internal
communications and even the intentions
uh in terms of strategy and so on this
is something that it has been put out as
an alert in the last couple of hours and
in terms of those claims by russia of a
drawdown the u.s secretary of state
saying that the intelligence that has
been seen by the united states indicates
just the opposite in fact they report
that they are seeing more bolstering of
russian forces along the border with
ukraine not less so
to that end given the fact that there is
this belief that there is still a window
of a potential for an imminent invasion
the u.s president joe biden will be
holding a consultation telephone call as
they continue to coordinate closely with
allies that phone call will be with the
german chancellor olaf schultz and that
will be taking place at 1930 gmt why is
this important because the german
chancellor was meeting in moscow just 24
hours ago with vladimir putin so
in the effort to try and continue to try
and de-escalate something the u.s
president says as a primary goal he is
working with his allies at the same time
preparing for any eventuality including
a russian invasion of ukraine kimberly
thank you for that kimberly harkett live
at the white house
well